let's do this let's talk about this
first uh this story that comes from The
Daily Beast from the uh internationally
renowned technologist technical expert
and expert on the far far far far far
far far far far right will summer oh I'm
kidding he's he's none of those things
magaz Maga world's Freedom phone
actually budget Chinese phone Maga
influencers are pushing a phone
preloaded with apps like parlor and
Rumble that appears to be a vastly more
expensive version of a phone made in
China the first thing I'm going to say
to this
well actually the first thing I should
say is will summer as a political
activist like I don't take anything he
says seriously and I don't understand
why there are people on the right people
who oppose censorship who are like well
will summer of all people said it will
Summers published false information in
the past uh uh and yeah I'll just leave
it at that
the dude is not an honest actor so why
should I care if he's making some
ridiculous argument in an article that's
clearly an opinion but not labeled
opinion because this dude is just trying
to probably grift now the thing about
The Daily Beast is they smear anybody
and everything that's to the right of
Stalin so for some reason this article
comes out and that's it now I've even
got people in the chat right now saying
it's a cheap Chinese knockoff have you
tested the phone do you know anything
about it I don't so I'm not going to
make that assessment but I can't say a
few things right off the bat
first
they say it's a knockoff of a cheap
Chinese phone well obviously you know
we're sitting here with Eric but I'll
just say this before we get into it and
I'll and I'll ask let me just say
if this is the way I described it on my
on my main Channel first of all I get it
I haven't tested the phone we want to do
a forensic analysis and go through it
but if I if someone was selling a
Chinese canvas and it was five dollars
you could buy it and order it off Amazon
and then if Ian painted me a beautiful
picture of a lighthouse on a canvas I
would not expect to pay the same price
for it if someone takes a a a a phone
that costs a hundred bucks and then puts
a custom operating system on it and
preloaded software and provides the
service and then charges more that's
just called free enterprise it's called
business how is that a negative and it's
made in China what isn't made in China
so these aren't arguments against the
freedom phone there certainly are
questions and concerns but uh we'll
start with this is it a cheap Chinese
knockoff of the Uma Digi A9 Pro
absolutely not we we customize the phone
uh itself so that way you know it's it's
so is that that way it was quality we
looked at their uh looked at looked at
the supply my chain of the phone of all
the parts that come from it just making
sure everything's secure everything's
safe but no I mean it's not and then two
in addition to just it being a custom
phone uh it's uh we did our own custom
operating system on it too is it made in
China uh yeah I mean that's that's the
thing is you can't make phones in the
United States uh which is terrible um I
mean even Motorola they put three
billion dollars into open opening up a
factory back in the day uh for making
smartphones
um but uh you know but didn't you tweet
that it wasn't made in mainland China
yeah yeah it's in Hong Kong it's out of
Hong Kong okay so unfortunately that's
China no yeah exactly when we feel like
that was our best option and I have
family out in Hong Kong and uh and
everything but yeah I mean you still you
still get that I mean we get our our uh
uh we get stuck parts from uh from
Taiwan as well but then yet they still
call that China and all that so I mean
it's it's it's just China you know it's
a special economic zone exactly it is
it's made by Uma Digi uh we
I think so yeah I mean we we get some of
our stuff from Umi DG and all that stuff
um but uh but yeah we partnered with
them and uh so we basically we have a
Design Lab in the United States uh so
that way we can uh uh uh so we we so
I'll go through in the beginning of the
process so we actually wanted to create
like a blockchain based phone which is
you know a little bit marketing there
but uh but my background is crypto and
that was the original thinking so uh me
and my Design Lab which is here in the
US we're like how do we do a phone
there's template designs of a phone that
we can look at where there's other
phones we wanted to look at and see what
what can we take the best of everything
um and then yeah we uh uh we end up
putting something together and we tried
finding manufacturers
um in the US to do it but it was
literally impossible
um to find manufacturers in the US like
it's just you know because of terrible
political choices made uh you just can't
make a phone in the US and you need like
10 billion to Apple they have hundreds
of billions of dollars and they don't
choose to do it they could probably
figure out that much money well let's
try and get as technical as possible yep
uh can you who manufactures the fun in
Hong Kong what company DG and then we
get another Factory as well um because I
mean not not to sound marketing but we
did have high demands now we have
another Factory
um as well so that way we're
manufacturing stuff out of there but
they're both Umi Digi uh one is um dg1's
another one oh okay what is that one uh
that one I mean they just have a long
you know Hong Kong name and all that but
uh they're they're just basically to
carry the demand um that that overflows
but yeah we partnered with uh can you
say what company it is uh no I mean they
I I well I could but I don't uh I don't
remember their name or I do remember
their name in my head I can see it but
it's they that's a very it's a very
Asian that could be important I mean
what if it's like a known company that
works with the CCP or something uh they
don't and we looked into that so well
and sure I guess don't take my word for
it yeah we can't I mean Uma Digi is one
thing I can be like oh okay it's a
company that makes phones but now
there's like this mystery other company
we don't know what it is yeah I mean
they're we they're just an overflow
Factory that does production and all
that and we we talked with them we
looked at what they do and they have no
connections to the CCP or anything well
that's tough how are people supposed to
trust the phone now if you can't even
say where it's made um well I mean it's
made in Hong Kong uh and all that but by
who I mean umidigi and then yeah I mean
they're just a people they're just a
group of people that do uh uh you know
increase production the other company
yeah and then we have Representatives
only known and like you can look at the
name of the company and all the stuff
and like yeah hear how people find out
I'll put it on our website right after
this no worries all right yeah on our on
our spec sheet we're going to be adding
um you know sourcing of where we get
every single part from right on and just
to clarify uh Apple and Google also make
their phones in China right yeah I mean
I feel like that's the real stories and
in my opinion I think Apple chooses not
to make their phones the United States
because uh you know unfortunately I
don't have billions of dollars like
Motorola they try doing it with uh with
uh three billion dollars and they
couldn't do it back in the day
um and uh like I think they're doing
that with the Moto X Etc
um and uh you know Apple they have tens
of billions of dollars
um I think it was uh there was a former
president that asked Apple to actually
make phones in the U.S because they you
know it would be like a 30 billion
dollar Endeavor
um in my opinion and uh and they choose
not to so that's I feel like the real
story of these these companies is they
choose not to make stuff in the U.S and
when you're an upstart and you don't
have tens of billions of dollars to be
able to like set up whole new brand new
factories uh in the United States you
know it's it's you're screwed so one of
the other things they mention in The
Daily Beast article is that there's no
specs but you immediately just put the
specs on the web yeah the specs are on
the website and you can look at them and
everything what's the website Freedom
freedomfone.com so feel free to look on
the specs and everything yeah I looked
at the specs I'm kind of just like okay
like their specs yeah I don't I don't
understand I I suppose the argument is
if people didn't know the specs they
didn't know what they were buying but I
find that also kind of weird because I'm
like most people don't know what any of
this stuff means yeah like you know know
a f8 megapixels r13 plus two plus two MP
like most people are gonna be like I
don't know yeah you're gonna look at
that around what they're talking about
what is that r13 plus two plus two
Arthur so that's uh r13 so that's like
uh uh front facing camera versus and
rear facing camera so the f is front R
is is rear facing and then plus two
means that there's two cameras plus two
and there's multiple cameras on the back
what do the multiple cameras do what are
they for uh I mean you know just I feel
these days because you need phones that
work with augmented reality that takes
usually multiple cameras
um and then yeah I mean be able to have
like depth in your photos I mean
multiple cameras just all help with that
so I mean zoom in zoom out yeah exactly
so just being able to match
um uh uh the phone you know being able
to match phones of today with something
good in quality I couldn't help but
notice there's no 5G though there's no
5G yeah I mean 5G is just like like real
genuine 5gs just in like a few blocks in
a few cities
um and all that so and we we started on
this phone like a year ago yeah you guys
were explaining to me before the show
that 5G phones are different than the
five gigahertz Network yes yes that has
confused me for years I had no idea
until so here's here's the craziest
thing to me is the amount of smear
pieces that have that have popped up and
that that right away I'm just like
that's a red flag it's like when new
phones come out from Google or for from
whoever else Huawei someone will be like
this phone sucks someone will be like
well you know there's the pros and the
cons I've seen so many tech reviews and
I've seen so many devices to see all of
these companies all these news outlets
every single one line up in lockstep
with the advice not to buy the phone I
was like
now that I find very strange considering
they've never tested the phone and
there's really no issue to be upset with
it if the phone doesn't do what it says
it's a phone whatever I've I used I used
to I I've developed a few apps myself
with my one of my business partners I've
done a ton of work in Mobile hacking
phones and hacking other devices making
programs and I've I've probably owned
like a thousand different smartphones
throughout the production stuff we've
done there's so many different kinds and
and what people got to realize too
when you when you travel and this is
back in the day they use different
frequencies for all the cell antennas so
when I would go to like turkey the
specific frequency I'd have to check to
make sure certain devices worked with
certain phones GSM typically worked in
most places so getting a GSM phone be
okay but like Ukraine was actually CDMA
so I'd have to go and buy a new phone
and they got phones that you can buy
from Samsung in Eastern Europe you can't
buy in the United States and they're
cheap and anyway I'm just like okay so
it's a phone if somebody wants to buy it
because it's got oiana n on it or parlor
or or Newsmax or whatever what's the
problem now it could be that all of
these news outlets are simply just hey
there here's another let's smear them
because we'll get clicks Their audience
expects to hate Trump they called you
Mago world they're trying to put you in
that in that category simply for you
know the kinds of sites that are or apps
that are put on the phone
so maybe it's just a grift they all
decided it's fair game they can attack
you and you're not going to do anything
about it and you know what hey the
reality is I think most people James
O'Keefe is probably the only person who
actually does Sue for defamation and go
after people and and who Bloomberg
Bloomberg Michael Bloomberg yeah I think
he's super defamation a lot yeah but I'm
talking about the right James Oak keeps
like the only one who does it okay to be
fair Candace Owens we'll talk maybe talk
about that in a bit just had her her
suit dismissed but very few people try
and one of the most annoying things
whenever I've dealt with defamation the
advice I usually get from people on the
right is just to ignore it blah blah
blah because you know and I'm like why
just Sue and make your argument make a
better argument improve your arguments
and find the vector in which you can go
after the people who are lying but
anyway thanks for checking out this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast if you want
to see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8 pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read you your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time